Hello world,
it's Saroj and let's make our own speech.
Recognizer using tensorflow,
speech recognition has gotten so
much better in the past few decades.
In the 50s the general consensus amongst
computer scientists was that speech
signals needed to first be split
into little phonetic units.
Then those units could
be grouped into words,
but even though this seems
like it would work well,
this approach did not
give us good results.
The first ever speech
recognizer was called Audrey
by bell labs in 1952 it could
only recognize spoken numbers between
one and nine and was built with analog
electronic circuits. The
renowned scientist and BP
at Bell Labs, John Pearce,
Dan speech recognition research because
the results weren't promising enough,
but a small group of visionaries at
a newly formed team called Darpa,
went against popular opinion and
created a system called heartbeat.
It used 15,000 interconnected nodes and
each represented all of the possible
utterances within the domain.
That youth a brut force search algorithm
to map the speech to the right notes to
get the text. This approach was
slightly better, but then it blew,
invented something called
the hidden Markov Model.
Hmms represented utterances as states
and probabilistically predicted what a
word was given the phenoms it was made
up of when words like you are pronounced,
they can have different durations like
you or you and h and m's captured the
plasticity of words by using
a probabilistic approach.
The hmm pretty much maintained its
position as king of speech recognition
throughout the eighties and nineties as
researchers improve them more and more,
and some Weirdos kept trying this dumb
technique called artificial neural
networks, but of course it didn't
get good results. One of them,
this Guy Geoffrey Hinton kept on trying
out neural networks until all of a
sudden, a couple of years ago, it
started outperforming everything.
Did people tell you,
Jeffrey,
you're wasting your time many
times and would you say back,
give me another six months and
I'll prove to you that it works.
The key was to give it more
data and computing power.
This is deep learning. Now.
These deep neural nets are how services
like Siri and echo and Google now hear
you speak, and with Google's machine
learning framework tensor flow,
we're going to build our own deep neural
network that learns to recognize spoken
numbers. We're going to download a
labeled Dataset of people saying numbers,
build a neural network, train it
on that data, then test it out.
See if we can recognize
other spoken numbers.
It'll be 20 lines of python code and
I'll explain things as we go. Ready?
Let's first import TF Lauren.
Tia Florent is a high level library built
on top of tensorflow that is easier to
read and great for the past prototyping.
Our other import is a helper class
we've created called speech data.
This will help fetch data from
the web and format it for us.
Now that we have our libraries,
let's define our hyper parameters or
tuning knobs. We have three of them.
The first one is the learning rate.
The learning rate is what we apply
to this weight updating process.
The greater the learning rate,
the faster our network trains,
the lower the learning rate,
the more accurate our network predicts.
So it represents a tradeoff
between time and accuracy. Next,
we'll define how many steps we want
to train for 300,000 we have our hyper
parameters.
Now we can batch our data.
This is where we'll use our help
a class speech data specifically,
it's batch generator function. This
function will download a set of Wav files.
Each weight file is a recording
of a different spoken digit like
and each is labeled with a written digits.
It will return the list of
labeled speech files as a batch.
Then we can split our batch into training
and testing data with pythons built in
next function. We'll use the same
data for testing for simplicity,
so it'll be able to recognize a speaker
we trained it on, but not other speakers.
Now that we have our
training and testing data,
it's time to make our neural network,
so what kind of neural network
should we use for this?
I'm going to wrap the answer to this.
Did you drop out? Turn it up once a one
problem is classifying images, input,
image, output, label. Ain't no sequences.
I want to many problems. Gives them image,
captions, input image, output
sequence, and all of them abstractions.
A many to one problem is sentiment
analysis and puts sequence output positive
ain't no accident a problem that's many
to many is a sequence of waves output
sequence of words.
Then our model saves
since spoken words are a
sequence of sound waves.
We want to use a recurrent neural network
since they're capable of processing
sequences,
so we'll initialize our net by calling
TF Lauren's input data function.
This initial input layer
will be the gateway.
That data is fed into the network and
the parameter will help define the shape
of our input data or as tensorflow calls
it our input tenser and tenser is a
fancy word for a multidimensional array
of data are two parameters will be the
width and the height.
The width is the number of features that
are extracted from our utterances in
our speech. Data help reclass
and the height is the Max
length of each utterance.
For our next layer we use tee up learns
Lstm or long short term memory function
in a recurrent net.
The output data,
its contents is influenced not only
by the input we've just put in,
but by the entire history of
inputs through our recurring loop.
Lsts are the type of recurrent net that
can remember everything it's fed and
because of that they outperform
regular recurrent nets consistently.
We'll use our previous layer as our
first parameter it since we are feeding
tensors from one layer to the
next and the number of neurons.
There's not really a rule for knowing
how many neurons use in a layer.
Two few will lead to bad predictions and
too many will overfit to our training
data, meaning it won't generalize well
let's pick one 28 and then aren't dropout
value,
which says how much dropout do we want?
Dropout helps prevent overfitting by
randomly turning off some neurons during
training,
so data is forced to find
new paths between layers
allowing for more generalized
model.
Our next layer will be fully connected,
meaning every neuron in the previous
layer will be connected to its neurons and
our number of classes are 10 since
we are only recognizing 10 digits,
we'll set the activation
function to softmax,
which will convert numerical
data into probabilities. Lastly,
we'll create our output
layer as a regression,
which will output a single
predicted number four our utterance.
We're using the popular Adam optimizer
to minimize our categorical cross entropy
loss function over time so we
get a more accurate prediction.
Now we can initialize our
network using TF learns,
deep neural net function and set tensor
board verbose to three which means we
want a detailed visualization,
will initialize our training loop,
then fit our model to the training and
testing data for 10 epochs with our
specified batch size.
Then we'll predict a spoken digits
value from our training data.
We also make sure to save our bottle
for later use and print our results.
Let's run this thing.
Tf Learn has a nice log of important
training variables built in just from
running the fit function, so we don't have
to specify what things to print after.
It's done training,
it'll predict the digits.
And if we wanted to we could just record
ourselves saying a number and place it
in the data directory, then
predict that. So to break it down,
LSTM neural networks are using
state of the art speech recognition.
We can use TF,
learn to quickly build and train a deep
neural network to recognize speech and
good hyper parameters like the learning
rate are those that are balanced between
trade offs like time and accuracy.
The winner of the coding challenge
from the last video is mic. Then Holst.
The challenge was to generate text in
the style of Lord of the rings is NTF
learn mic trained an LSTM network on
again devilfish language, then headed out,
put new Gandel fish like yellow to low,
tease her,
refer that ass of the week.
No new coding challenge for this video
is the challenge from the make a video
game. But video is still running.
You haven't watched it yet.
Check out the link to it in the
description and the due date is Thursday,
December 15th at noon pst, which is
one week from today. Please subscribe.
And for now, I've got to get tickets to
ICLR next year, so thanks for watching.